new york
start spreading the news
we're all
gonna die
[Laughter]
so how do you survive a nuclear blast in
the city that already smells like ass
true new yorkers who are worried about
crime disease and inflation can now add
nuclear radiation
new york city's emergency management
department produced a psa or passage
on how to survive a nuclear bomb which
is exactly what i was worried about as a
naked man was fondling himself in front
of me on the r train
actually i was praying for a nuclear
bomb
roll it ricardo
so there's been a nuclear attack don't
ask me how or why just know that the big
one has hit okay so what do we do
there are three important steps that i
want you to remember
don't ask me how or why
well that's convenient
no back story on why we got nukes
i'll make up my own biden thought he was
pressing the button for the nurse
[Laughter]
but but please tell me the steps a lady
dressed like steve jobs
step one
get inside fast you your friends your
family get inside and no staying in the
car is not an option you need to get
into a building and move away from the
windows
step two
stay inside
shut all doors and windows
have a basement
head there
if you don't have one get as far into
the middle of the building as possible
so wow staying in cars is not an option
what will comedians like jamie do
i mean that's where that's where he
lives
or divorced comics that is but what if
you're outside after the blast
if you were outside after the blast get
clean immediately remove and bag all
outer clothing to keep radioactive dust
or ash away from your body
step 3
stay tuned
follow media for more information
don't forget to sign up for notifynyc
for official alerts and updates
and don't go outside until officials say
it's safe
alright
you've got this
you got this
sorry honey this is a nuclear war not a
pilates class
and remove and bag all outer clothing
that's what we do after we visit cat's
office
so why is new york giving instructions
now about a nuclear blast maybe mayor
adams is finally serious about getting
criminals off the streets
there are syringe-filled sidewalks and
insane asylum subway and the only people
getting arrested are those defending
themselves from attackers maybe the
city's strategy is to get us all inside
and then blow everything up which i am
against
but i do wish the city
would put out a psa to help us cope with
the real problems
so your city's been taken over by
progressives it's important for you to
understand your life is about to get a
lot worse but there are steps that you
can take to stay safe
step one
get inside progressive crime policies
mean your streets are about to become
violent drug-fueled homeless nightmares
step two
watch out for human excrement it's going
to be everywhere poor city planning
urban decay and lack of law enforcement
mean public streets are now public
bathrooms
step three
stay tuned to the media
the media know what's best for your
family the media are better than you
also don't get too attached to your
wallet
you're going to lose a lot of them
you've got this
on my phone too
lydia as a new yorker do you find this
uh helpful at all this uh nuclear war
prep video i could use a psa for how not
to get pushed in front of a train yes
that might be helpful no my theory on
this there are 325 000 new york city
employees and i think they have to do
something to justify
the tax payer dollars
and this is very reminiscent to me of if
you remember in covid the city released
a guideline for how to have safe sex
while wearing an n95 mask right that was
great this is very much in the genre
of things that if people had better
things to be doing they wouldn't be
doing
yeah i disagree i think the bomb's
coming yeah but you know what sucked
about i mean the whole thing about
telling you to wear that m93 mask during
sex you have to put it over the other
mask
yeah there's a lot of protection that
they wanted people to have
you don't have to answer that
and the red ball gets in the way
[Music]
can't hear the safe
word a lot of confusion oh my god cat
yep
do you find this helpful
no because
i feel like if i'm in the midst of a
nuclear bomb attack i'm not going to
remember like the video yeah and
or anything i'm going to run around
screaming i'm going to be somebody
else's problem that's you know just like
i'm in any crisis yeah exactly yeah i
i'm not i'm not
walking dead
i don't want to be somebody protecting
people from the walking dead well i just
won't be able to and again the fact that
they start with don't ask me how don't
ask me why i want to whenever i want to
ask why i can't ask why yeah
jamie they just gave us
another reason to leave the city
right it's like
think about this what the subliminal
thing is we only bomb big cities anyway
so it's like here's another reason to
get the hell out of new york and go to
austin or go to nashville they're a bit
this is basically a video telling you to
leave it is like we need more stuff like
to scare us do we need more stuff i feel
like the next video they'll just be like
boo
[Laughter]
you know what though
i'm so glad i saw this psa because i i
memorized all the steps because my old
plan if there was a nuclear attack was
just going to be to be vaporized
yeah
i'm i'm gonna do this instead maybe this
is their attempt to finally get rid of
all the cockroaches that's true but
they'll they'll definitely live the
cockroaches will win you know i did like
i like step three they were like wash
all your clothes i like it they've just
assumed that i had my pants
yeah but everyone would also do step
four right where you check the mirror
and see if it made you ugly
that's why you got to embrace this
that's
tyrus what did you you were like
couldn't hold it together because i
apparently
saw a different video than you guys
everything i heard was
you got about 15 minutes whoever's close
to you get inside have some fun you
don't even got to do it in the car
anymore you do it on the roof and as
soon as you get done find someone else
and get inside again like get in as many
as you can and don't they're not going
to not hear that they're not going to
ask how or why we've got 15 minutes
so
let's all just get weird let's just go
out that's well that's what i took it as
so don't ask don't tell because we're
not going to be around anyways so yes
you know yeah and if you and then you
have to stop oh but if you survive then
you have to start the whole race all
over again well we got a good start
before the 15th
get those few in because that's it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else